افادت مصادر محليه الجزيره بان الجيش
التركي قصف مواقع لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في محيط المدينه منبج بريف
حلب الشماليه سوريه
على ريفاييل الحسكه والرقه فيستهدف عده
مواقع لما تعرف بقوات السوريه الديمقراطيه
في هذه الاثا اكد مجلس الامن القومي
التركيه انه سيتم اتخاذه الخطوات اللازمه
لمنع نشاطي بالتنظيم الارهابي وكان وزير
الدفاع كارل عقب لقاء مع المبعوث
الامريكيه السابق لسوريه جيمس جفري في
انقره قال انها تركيا حضرت الدول
المتحالفه معها من دعم حزب العمال
الكردستاني او حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي لاي
سبب من الاسباب بما في ذلك ذريته محاربه
تنظيم الدوله
فكرنا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه طلبت من
تركيا اعاده تقييم العمليه العسكريه
في المقابل الوفاء بعدها وفقها تعبيرها
هذا هو قال مظلوم عبد القائد العام لما
تعرف بقوات السوريه الديمقراطيه انه على
روسيا ان تتحمل مسؤوليه ايقاف التصعيد
التركيه على المنطقه كونها دوله ضامنه
لاتفاق وقفه اطلاق النار المتفق عليه مع
تركيا وطلب عبده روسيا باعلان مواصفات
وان تطالبه تركيا بالالتزام بالاتفاقيات
السابقه وحل الخلافات بالحوار لا بالحرب